okay so to start off with shale gas it
is very easy if you live here in
southwestern Pennsylvania to think that
we are the center of the world on shale
gas but I wanted to start with telling
you that we're not shale gas is a global
phenomena and this is an image just to
show you some of the resources in shale
gas that we know about the very light
gray are areas in the world where we
just don't know so just about everywhere
we've looked indeed we do have shale gas
resources I will not say the words game
changer I will leave that to all of the
folks on the economic side but there is
a major resource in shale gas on the
planet and that is likely to change how
we deal with our energy resources and in
case you were unaware there's a lot of
water on the planet to just about
everywhere on the planet and if you look
at the world from space mostly you see
water but I'm here to tell you that all
that green stuff there's water
underneath that so almost everywhere
that you find shale you're also going to
find water what this means is that our
water resources and our shale resources
in fact all of our energy resources are
co-located on the planet so shale gas
extraction is of course going to happen
near water everything happens near water
we're up here on the surface of the
earth those tiny little bitty things you
can barely see the people I drew in here
that's us okay shale gas extraction
starts on the surface of the earth but
then of course we have to go down down
down down down down down down down down
down all the way down to where the shale
is drill through all of these layers of
earth through that tiny little sliver up
here that is the aquifer from which
you're receiving a lot of your drinking
water we have to go through all of those
resources to get to the shale we drill
through and we send water down through
in order to hydraulically fracture the
shale which is break the shell into
little bitty pieces so that the gas
flows back to the surface what that
means is that when you do this kind of
development it's critically important
that you protect the surface water from
spills of the chemicals that we use in
this operation and of the water that
comes back
to the surface that is hardly surprising
there are no industries really where you
wouldn't say there's a potential for
something affecting our water resources
it's also critical that we isolate
groundwater from this drilling activity
and from the hydraulic fracturing
chemicals that's a fairly unique aspect
of this industry but again all
industries affect our water resources
and our wastewater reason and generate
waste water shale gas extraction is
particularly known to use a lot of water
and to generate a significant amount of
produced water so a typical shale gas
operation and this is one in West
Virginia we'll start with 125 million
gallons of water perform a hydraulic
fracture operation generate ten to
fifteen percent of that water will come
back to the surface in the first couple
of weeks and then water continually is
produced out of these formations along
with the gas that's a significant amount
of wastewater to deal with we call that
water produced water because it's
produced when the gas is produced when
the gas stops so does that water but all
the time that the gas is coming up we
get water that kind of looks like this
now if you're from southwestern
Pennsylvania that just looks like the
red water we have here everywhere but
I'm here to tell you that it's a lot
worse than the kind of things we see in
acid mine drainage because it's highly
concentrated it contains the residuals
from everything we put into the
hydraulic fracturing as well as some
naturally occurring radioactive
materials a lot of salt and some
chemicals that we typically find with
hydrocarbons benzene toluene
ethylbenzene that water has to be
managed and dealt with as it comes up
from those formations so first
understand that a million gallons of
water kicks up a particular considerable
amount of space we have to store the
water on site we have to store the
wastewater when it comes back up every
so often you're going to have to go back
to every single well and pick up the
wastewater you're going to pick it up in
trucks we're going to truck the water to
the site truck the waste water away from
the site there's a significant increase
in truck traffic and in the potential to
have accidents with these trucks full of
waste we of course can also treat it I
like to tell my students that
I can take any water you give me and
make it drinkable all it takes is a
little money a little energy and I can
go from the worst sewage you ever
invented to completely potable water but
of course energy is why we're drill in
the wells so you got to be careful with
how much energy you're going to spend to
clean up the water that's coming back up
you can also disposed of this water down
deep wells you may have heard of this
technique here again us on the surface
of the planet deep underground there are
locations where we can put ways we do
quite a bit of underground injection in
this country a billion gallons a day of
produced water is injected somewhere in
the United States to dispose of it so
there's a lot of water going into deep
underground injection so I only have a
little bit of time so I'm not going to
be able to tell you really about how
much water and how much waste water
we're talking about globally but I did
want to briefly tell you about a little
the work taking place here related to
this issue so now I'm going to focus
down remember it's a global problem but
I'm only going to talk about
Pennsylvania how much water does it
really take how much waste water do we
really get so first on the how much
water this is some work from a couple of
my colleagues and engineering and public
policy Austin Mitchell and Liz kasmin
who have been looking at here in
southwestern Pennsylvania how much water
withdrawal are we using now those of you
who live here have said you know it
rains every day really who cares how
much water they want but we did take a
really careful look at how much water
are we talking about water is withdrawn
both from small creeks and streams and
rivers that surface water supply may be
around 50 55 million gallons a day is
permitted withdrawals into marcellus
shale development and then public water
supply you probably can't see but these
are fire hydrants or they would be fire
hydrants but their hydrants lined up for
shale gas water sales so public water
supply maybe 35 million gallons a day so
we're talking about something around 90
million gallons a day of water going
into this industry that sounds like a
lot of water Pennsylvania American and
Pittsburgh water and sewer our water
companies here Pittsburgh water and
sewer withdrawals 100 million
gallons a day for just the city of
Pittsburgh so we're talking about the
water use of a mid-sized can we say big
can we say Pittsburgh is a big city big
city so about the same water use of a
midsize city in the United States it's
not a lot of water what tends to matter
on water is where you're getting in
small creeks are impacted more than if
you want to take this out of the
Monongahela River if you want to take
this out of Aetna during flooding we're
all okay with that how much waste water
last thing I want to talk about is what
happens to all of that produced water so
this is some analysis my group has done
looking at produced water volumes in
Pennsylvania 2000 12 2011 total produced
water we know for this first period and
then we know it broken apart for
Marcellus and non after that so about 10
million barrels or so of produced water
maybe a little less 8 to 10 million
barrels of produced water were being
produced every year in Pennsylvania for
a really really long time we've been
drilling holes in the ground for
hydrocarbon extraction in Pennsylvania
for more than 100 years so this is our
background produced water levels in 2008
with a sharp increase in Marcellus Shale
drilling we saw a significant increase
in sorry about that in produced water
loads coming out in two thousand eight
and nine a drop in 10 and 11 with a
significant increase in recycling within
the Marcellus Shale formation but you
still see now that we know the
conventional from the Marcellus so this
dark blue down here looks kind of a lot
like it's looked forever right so sorry
about that again so our produced water
levels from conventional have stayed
about the same but the Marcellus
production is generating a lot more of
this water we need to manage and deal
with about twice as much as conventional
in 2010 and about three times as much as
conventional in 2011 so what's the story
with water and shale gas protecting the
ground in the surface water while we're
doing the development managing the water
withdrawals it's not too much water but
you have to be careful about where
you're taking it from protecting the
water resources when we transmit when we
when we ship this material and when we
store it and then finally appropriate
treating that significantly increased
volume of waste water that we're seeing
and with that I will just remind
everyone in the room that professors
don't do work students do and so on this
side are all the graduate and
undergraduate researchers who have
helped with the research that I've just
presented to you and our funders
steinbrenner the arcs cocom and Heinz
endowments have all provided funding for
this research thank you
you